[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité un siècle
d'absence et le voilà de retour la
présence du loup et désormais officielle
en Bretagne une réapparition qui n'est
pas sans causer quelques problèmes comme
vous l'expliquera TVR dès le début de ce
journal à Rennes eux se font rares les
saisonniers manquent à l'appel à
quelques semaines de l'été dans la baie
de Somme les restaurateurs multiplient
les astuces pour séduire des candidats
les détails à suivre avec WeHo TV la
chaîne de la Voix du Nord et puis il
sera aussi question de courage et de
sport dans ce journal avec vous le
verrez le défi relevé ou la main par des
résidentes d'un EHPAD grimpé à pied le
premier étage de la Tour Eiffel un
exploit suivi par la rédaction de Canal
32 dans l'autre et puis jeune et
ambitieux en fin de journal la rédaction
de 8 monts blancs nous dressera le
portrait de Nine mélasseen un boxeur de
24 ans qui rêve de championnats du monde
voilà il n'y a plus de doute le loup et
de retour en Bretagne en tout cas cela
faisait près d'un siècle que l'animal
n'avait pas été aperçu dans la région et
comme par tout ailleurs la présence du
loup n'est pas sans causer des débats
sur place entre attaque de troupeau et
défense de l'espèce le point avec ce
sujet de Frédéric Lorenzo pour la chaîne
TVA arrête de regarder
le loup est de retour en Bretagne après
un siècle d'absence est une certitude
depuis l'enregistrement de cette image
le 4 mai 2022 à Berrien dans les Monts
d'Arrée le loup laisse aussi d'autres
traces cet éleveur estime avoir perdu
plusieurs dizaines de brebis à cause du
loup moi j'ai eu déjà cinq attaques
depuis le 15 décembre 2022 qui se sont
soldés par plus de 25 animaux tués je
sais que ce sont des attaques de look
pour plusieurs raisons la première
raison c'est sur la façon dont l'animal
a été consommé et ensuite j'ai fait
faire des années génétiques en effet à
chaque attaque supposée de loups les
agents de l'Office français de la
biodiversité enquête pour indemniser ou
non l'éleveur mais les analyses
génétiques ne sont pas systématiquement
réalisés clairement aujourd'hui
l'analyse génétique permet de d'attester
avec assurance que la prédation est bien
liée à un loup ou pas donc faut savoir
que par exemple sur les votre attaque
que j'ai eu il y a qu'une seule attaque
qui a été attestée là où il y avait les
autres attaques ou c'était aussi du
lourd pour être indemnisé l'éleveur doit
aussi montrer qu'il protège son troupeau
notamment avec les chiens pour cet élu
très impliqué dans le dossier loup ses
chiens sont inadaptés en Finistère ce
genre de protection mais ils peuvent
s'en prendre également aux humains alors
quand c'est sur une arrachement de
renona 2009 altitude parfois les maires
ferme le chemin de randonnée mais nous
en Bretagne si c'est une ferme qui a 150
mètres du bourg de la commune et on
ferme quoi je souhaiterait c'est que ce
temps qui nous est imparti avant que la
catastrophe arrive c'est que
il soit mis en place une étude d'impact
l'arrêté du 19 juillet 2019 fixe une
indemnisation entre 58 et 720 euros par
brebis selon la qualité de la bête
envisagez le pire pour éviter un maximum
de dégâts direction la Gironde dans ce
journal ou des brigades de pompiers
s'entraînent déjà à lutter contre les
feux de forêt les incendies de l'été
dernier sont encore gravés dans les
mémoires alors mieux vaut être prêt pour
les chaleurs et la saison estivale qui
arrive une mise en situation suivie par
Yvan branchy pour TV7 la chaîne du
groupe sud-ouest sur place
après plusieurs mois à l'arrêt il faut
retrouver les automatismes
[Musique]
cet exercice grandeur nature intervient
lorsque le risque sur le massif est
modéré et c'est une nouveauté pour les
soldats du feu c'est un groupe
d'intervention feu de forêt qui est
constitué de 4 camions et de ne véhicule
léger en route on met en pratique nos
techniques opérationnelles et on
maintient nos compétences une mise en
situation sur le lac de Blagon
environnement idéal pour perfectionner
les techniques de lutte face aux flammes
en prévision d'une nouvelle saison à
haut risque projeté des éléments humains
et matériels au cœur du massif aussi
dans une démarche dissuasive aussi dans
une démarche préventive à l'égard des
promeneurs à l'égard de la population
l'idée étant de montrer que les
sapeurs-pompiers au même titre que les
forces de l'ordre des sylviculteurs sont
présentes dans le massif pour assurer sa
surveillance une surveillance mener
également à plus de 40 mètres de haut 21
tours de gai comme celle-ci sont
réparties sur le territoire girondin un
panorama à 360° sur le massif qui permet
d'indiquer rapidement au groupe
d'intervention un départ de fumée
traditionnellement on est sur un ordre
de grandeur d'une dizaine de minutes ce
qui est relativement court entre le
moment où effectivement le guetteur
détecte la fumée et le moment où les
camions les premiers camions arrivent
ce délai va être raccourci notamment par
le concours des gifs un délai réduit
davantage avec l'installation prochaine
de 8 caméras ce qui permettra de
surveiller 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7 le massif et de réintégrer les 25
guetteurs dans les centres de secours
voilà il n'y a pas que les pompiers qui
préparent la haute saison les
restaurateurs aussi et vous le savez
déjà ils sont nombreux à rencontrer des
difficultés de recrutement les
saisonniers se font rares par tout en
France et notamment en Baie de Somme où
les professionnels redoublent d'astuces
pour attirer les candidats reportage de
Jérôme Aubron TV la chaîne de la Voix du
Nord et du Courrier Picard
dernier préparatif avant le coup de feu
de midi pas de stress dans ce restaurant
de la Côte Picarde une quinzaine de
salariés assurent le service c'est
suffisant du moins hors saison là pour
bien pour renforcer les effectifs il
faut encore trois serveurs et il me
manquerait encore on va dire un
cuisinier voir un plongeur la chasse aux
saisonniers commence à portante avec
elles sont lot de difficultés trouver de
la main d'oeuvre en restauration n'est
pas chose facile alors cette année
Jean-Philippe redouble d'astuces voilà
ici ça sera le studio pour les
saisonniers donc capacité une à deux
personnes un logement que le
restaurateur aménage dans l'espoir de
séduire plus facilement de potentiels
salariés ça vaut la peine je pense
au moins ils sont sur place moins de
fatigue pas de tracas en sachant que
est-ce qu'ils vont partir est-ce qu'ils
vont revenir ça aussi car en Baie de
Somme le manque de logement et leur prix
ont de quoi refroidir les saisonniers
alors pas le choix les professionnels de
l'hôtellerie restauration s'adapte tout
va bien ça donne quoi aujourd'hui ici
les frais de déplacement des salariés
les plus éloignés sont prises en charge
à hauteur de 200 euros par mois
quasiment tous mes salariés en fait à
peu près à trajet d'une cinquantaine de
kilomètres par jour ce qui veut dire que
ça grève et automatiquement leur salaire
il y a deux avantages en fait c'est que
c'est des fiscalisé ce qui veut dire que
le salarié c'est une bonus c'est tout
bénef pour lui et pour ma part c'est pas
chargé donc techniquement on s'y
retrouve mutuellement au Crotoy avant la
crise de la covid la location d'un
appartement s'élevait en moyenne à 500
euros la semaine cette année encore
soumise à un contexte d'inflation la
saison estivale s'annonce bel et bien
tendue
Nicolas meilleur Rossignol était
l'invité je dis matin de l'émission Face
au territoire sur TV5 Monde le maire de
Rouen est premier secrétaire délégué du
Parti socialiste et notamment revenu sur
la place de son parti dans le paysage
politique français regardez cette
extrait on a besoin que le Parti
socialiste se remette au travail il y a
une forme de paradoxe c'est à dire
qu'effectivement le Parti socialiste
peut être vu comme en très grande
difficulté comme vous l'avez décrit et
en même temps c'est vraiment ce que je
vois moi sur le terrain beaucoup de
françaises Français ne se satisfont pas
du paysage politique actuel est-ce que
vous avez beaucoup de gens qui ont le
cœur à gauche qui ont pu voter Monsieur
Mélenchon madame Hidalgo qui ont pu
voter Emmanuel Macron aussi sauf
qu'Emmanuel Macron il sera plus candidat
et si aujourd'hui attend d'une parole de
gauche et qui d'autre qui d'autre que
les socialistes pour porter cette parole
de gauche crédible qui rassemble moi je
pense qu'on a besoin d'une équipe vous
avez parlé de tension etc mais
franchement Rocard Mitterrand il passait
pas leurs vacances ensemble j'ose pas
puisqu'on a cité monsieur Fabius passez
par leurs vacances ensemble Aubry Royal
non plus et pourtant à cette époque le
Parti socialiste a gagné des élections à
changer la vie donc je crois qu'en
réalité il y a un débat qui est sain sur
l'avenir de la gauche
au territoire avec Nicolas mayorossignol
et avoir ou à revoir sur le site
internet de TV5 Monde et des partenaires
de l'émission où est cette France
Nice-Matin France anti 20 minutes la
montagne et le magazine Le Point le
point justement qui sort cette semaine
une édition spéciale consacrée à la
ville de Bordeaux l'hebdomadaire vous
dévoile notamment les bons plans
gastronomiques pour profiter de la
douceur bordelaise le marché immobilier
est également évoqué dans cette édition
spéciale du point à retrouver chez vos
marchands de journaux l'actualité des
médias c'est aussi la présence en
kiosque du deuxième numéro de
géostratégie magazine donc vous voyez la
une à l'écran actuellement Tom Benoît le
directeur de la rédaction du magazine
s'est entretenu il y a quelques jours
avec un res Youssef l'ancien conseiller
du président ukrainien Victor lucianko
et créateur de la Fondation Gaïa
l'occasion notamment de l'interroger sur
la tenue en novembre prochain de la
cop28 à Dubaï un choix étonnant au
regard des enjeux environnementaux
écoutez sa réponse lors d'un entretien
enregistré à Genève au Palais des
Nations Unies
Dubaï est le symbole de l'énergie
pétrolière il semblerait plutôt que les
politiques soient accès aujourd'hui sur
les énergies renouvelables est-ce qu'il
faut lire ici un symbole le fait que la
cop28 qui porte principalement sur le
changement climatique et lieu à Dubaï à
la fin de l'année il y a deux maillots
de notre planète plus influents que le
G20 et plus influent que le G7
accrue et naturellement plus les
questions de la santé de notre planète
de la santé de notre écosystème et posé
de manière forte plus il est difficile
pour l'État d'y répondre
il me semble que le fait de repousser la
coque vers des régions où le problème
environnemental n'est pas le plus urgent
parce qu'il y a des problèmes plus
pressants dans cette région qui doivent
être traités en priorité par rapport à
l'environnement est une démarche visant
à réduire la pression sur les principaux
états du monde qui eux doivent répondre
d'une imminente catastrophe mondiale
et de l'avenir de la planète il en était
également question à Monaco lors du
Sommet international muse consacrée au
metaves durant trois jours les
principaux acteurs de cette industrie
florissante se sont donné rendez-vous
dans la principauté l'occasion de
découvrir certaines des nouvelles
technologies qui façonneront nos vies
futures propos recueillis par Théo Pitou
et Stéphane Attia sur place on l'a vu
arriver à Monaco les acteurs majeurs
l'avenir de votre vie quotidienne je
suis très ému parce qu'il y a des grands
grands sociétés qui a profité et
utiliser le présence ici pour faire de
l'annonce qui a impact sur la vie
quotidienne tout le monde
et à ce propos s'il y a bien une
problématique qui impacte notre
quotidien c'est celle de la production
énergétique passer d'un modèle fossile à
un modèle vertueux c'est évidemment la
promesse des énergies renouvelables dans
la Sarthe vous allez le voir la filière
éolienne est porteuse de débouchés
professionnels mais encore faut-il la
faire connaître au plus jeune c'est
l'objectif justement de la Fédération
Française énergique qui organise des
visites au plus près des parcs éoliens à
reportage de Laurent Girard pour LM TV
Sarthe
les regards sont souvent en l'air et
pour cause ce groupe d'élèves du lycée
sud du Mans s'est déplacé entre
douaniers et Courgain pour découvrir ce
qu'est une éolienne pendant deux heures
toutes les questions sont évoquées sans
tabou combien de mètres on doit être des
habitations
sensibles aux questions
environnementales on comprend comment ça
marche et on va pouvoir expliquer aussi
aux autres après c'est ça qui est
intéressant les trois machines du parc
Nord-Sarthe 2 alimente annuellement 6500
foyers leurs mains culmine à 110 mètres
de haut
170 mètres avec les pales et cette
mécanique doit être entretenue et
régulièrement surveillée c'est là
qu'intervient l'ingénieur exploitation
qui parle aujourd'hui de son métier on
travaille au quotidien c'est vérifier le
bon fonctionnement des éoliennes piloter
les choses à prévoir sur chaque parc
éolien des métiers qui se développent en
même temps que le parc éolien français
est nigérien la région Pays de la Loire
est particulièrement avancée dans le
domaine mais la seconde région en termes
d'emploi dans l'éolien mais à 2000
peut-être 2600 emplois dans la filière
éolienne
qu'il s'orientent vers des filières
générales ou technologiques ces jeunes
ont pu découvrir des dizaines de métiers
portés par ces éoliennes
voilà et de l'éolienne aux moulin avant
dans ce journal direction le Tarn pour
découvrir ces très belles images de l'un
des derniers moulins encore en
fonctionnement d'Occitanie restaurer il
y a une trentaine d'années celui-ci
tourne comme au XVIIe siècle et permet
toujours la fabrication de farine
explications et images récoltées par
Manon aussi de la Dépêche du Midi notre
partenaire sur place je suis très
contente de travailler ici c'est vrai
qu'on s'en lasse pas tous les jours de
monter au moulin et le mettre en route
quand on peut et de produire de la
farine et c'est très très satisfaisant
le premier je vais vérifier la météo et
en fonction de la météo justement je
vais pouvoir adapter les voilures à
l'extérieur je vais savoir effectivement
si je vais toutes les installer en
fonction de la puissance du vent je
saurai si le moulin va tourner au cours
de la journée
allez sans transition que diriez-vous de
grimper 327 marches des filles pour le
moins sportif que vient de relever 6
résidentes d'un EHPAD troyen
âgé de 84 à 99 ans ces seniors ont monté
à pied jusqu'au premier étage de la Tour
Eiffel un pari relevé en lettres
capitales suivies par la rédaction de
Canal 32 dans l'Aude regardez
avant de commencer l'ascension leur est
à l'échauffement pour ses 6 résidentes
d'EHPAD d'ici quelques minutes elle
graviront 327 marches pour atteindre le
premier étage de la Tour Eiffel
je l'ai fait il y a peut-être 40 ans
mais je me suis bien plus bien vous les
sentez comment ce matin voilà toujours
un petit peu de un petit peu de stress
content d'être ici pour tout le monde et
puis et puis impatient de pouvoir monter
les premières marches 11h
15 l'ascension les seniors âgés de
99 ans
ça se passe bien pour l'instant dans le
groupe de tête rose Jeanne et Monique on
arrive doucement au bout on y arrive je
crois qu'on est à la fin la presse
84 ans est la première à atteindre le
sommet en 30 minutes seulement j'aurais
jamais cru faire ça un jour un bon âge
je suis ravie
Geneviève 99 ans la doyenne du groupe
arrivant dernier après 40 minutes
d'ascension
40 minutes pour monter ces 327 marches
sachant qu'elle a loupé en plus un mois
et demi d'entraînement on sait jamais
quand même
des choses comme ça
vous pouvez vous pirer c'est super
mission accomplie pour les six
résidentes une fierté pour le personnel
de l'espace Saint-Vincent de Paul
ce projet un peu fou au final avec avec
les beaux sourires que vous avez
aujourd'hui c'est magnifique la vie
s'arrête pas à 60 ans 70 qui a n'importe
quel âge on peut se donner un objectif
quand on est correctement accompagné ça
fonctionne très très bien une fois
remise de leur effort les résidents ont
pu profiter d'un bon restaurant et d'une
balade sur la Seine
voilà et bravo à elle pour leur
performance ils sont un peu les anges
gardiens de vos balades en forêt les
rando pisteurs sont en pleine action ces
temps-ci pour nettoyer les chemins
empruntés par les randonneurs objectif
tout faire pour assurer la sécurité des
promeneurs avec le retour des beaux
jours comme a pu le constater juste une
barreau pourvient Occitanie regardez
dans la forêt de l'escandorgues les
rando pisteurs de l'Hérault s'activent
pour préparer la saison après l'hiver et
les grands vents du printemps leur est
au nettoyage des sentiers de randonnée
la première des choses c'est la sécurité
des usagers dans un premier temps déjà
par un balisage régulier et voyant et
ensuite par les mises en sécurité du
débroussaillage pour que l'itinéraire
reste bien voyage et essayer de gérer
d'anticiper tous les problèmes qui ont
qu'on peut rencontrer par de la chute de
branche ou la chute d'arbre dans
les horaires de randonnée pédestres
cycliste ou même équestre un large
parcours à entretenir pour lequel les
usagers n'hésitent pas à alerter les
rando pisteurs on a des usagers qui
utilisent une application qui s'appelle
suricate où on fait remonter les
dysfonctionnements qui peut y avoir un
arbre tombé par exemple et il nous
préviennent même si on a des patrouilles
qui sont faites régulièrement pour les
agences ça nous fait un retour Stéphane
et son équipe sont de vrai passionnés
incollables sur la forêt dont ils
prennent le plus grand soin au point
d'agir pour la
biodiversités
favoriser quelque part un petit peu de
nidification de certains oiseaux qui
sont des gros prédateurs de des
chenilles de la pyrale on s'est dit que
peut-être mais nous on a notre petit
niveau on arriverait à faire quelque
chose
va falloir installer plusieurs nichoirs
à mésanges ainsi que des abris pour les
chauves-souris ces petites maisons de
bois ont aujourd'hui tout trouvé leur
locataires
une très bonne action pour la
biodiversité qui nous conduit en Guyane
à présent dans cette édition la bas ce
sont les tortues luttes qui sont
menacées de disparition alors pour
tenter de sauvegarder cette espèce un
plan national d'action a été créé il y a
15 ans ONG et associations mènent ainsi
des projets sur le terrain comme la
construction d'une écloserie pour
protéger les autres tortues la pêche
illégale est également dans le viseur du
gouvernement les précisions avec ce
reportage de Franck Chassagnon et
danache ça et des hauts
c'est peut-être la solution de la
dernière chance quelques piquets plantés
dans le sable en bord de mer et un
grillage pour protéger les œufs d'une
espèce menacée d'extinction
l'association quatta qui lutte depuis 25
ans en Guyane pour préserver les tortues
en partenariat avec la réserve naturelle
d'Amana n'a pas eu d'autre choix que
d'installer ce parc une écloserie
artificielle c'est une écloserie qui va
accueillir les pompes de tortue luth qui
sont déposées par les femelles qui
arrivent sur la plage d'awalaï Mako
malheureusement ces ponts sont trop
souvent braconnées ou attaqués par des
chiens errants d'une part d'autre part
les adultes sont trop souvent capturés
par les pêches illégales qui viennent du
Suriname donc toutes ces raisons ont
amené à ce qui est nécessité de créer
cette écloserie après la ponte chaque
nid de tortue lutte sera déplacée par la
main de l'homme pour le mettre à l'abri
dans cet enclos face à sa diminution
vraiment très importante des tortues
luttes sur Awala on s'est dit là on est
vraiment sur une opération pratiquement
de dernière chance on aurait tous bien
aimé ne pas en arriver là bien
évidemment
euh mais voilà l'an dernier il y a eu 72
ou 73 pompes à wallah donc 80000 dans
les années 80 et donc là on se dit bah
voilà c'est quelques tortues qui
viennent encore pondre il faut
absolument qu'on arrive à soustraire les
nids des menaces qu'elles peuvent encore
trouver sur la plage et pour aller plus
loin dans cette démarche de sauvegarde
de la tortue luth le secrétaire d'État
chargé de la mer a aussi annoncé un plan
de lutte contre la pêche illégale j'ai
annoncé une nouvelle unité un nouveau
bateau qui sera basé tout près d'ici à
irakubo et qui permettra parce que c'est
une unité plus petite plus mobile
d'aller pour chasser les pêcheurs
illégaux le plus loin possible notamment
ceux qui vont dans l'embouchure il y a
un état le Suriname qui a vu sa
biodiversité ses ressources s'effondrer
parce que il y a beaucoup de surpêche
parce que c'est un état qui est pauvre
et donc si on veut travailler sur le
long terme et moi j'y crois beaucoup
c'est avec l'aide au développement il y
a donc encore beaucoup pas faire pour
sauver cette tortue lutte qui est
menacée à chaque instant de sa vie une
goutte d'eau pour un combat dont les
armes ne sont pas égales mais il reste
encore un espoir à l'image de ce bébé
tortue sauver des croûtes d'un chien
errant par un agent de la réserve
naturelle qui a pu prendre le large dans
l'océan
[Musique]
avec la 76e édition du Festival de
Cannes événement majeur pour le 7e art
la quinzaine et l'occasion vous le savez
pour les réalisateurs et les acteurs de
briller aux yeux du monde entier mais
derrière les strass et les paillettes
les petites mains s'actives pour la
réussite d'un film parmi elles celle des
monteurs et des monteuses qui sont
évidemment absolument essentiels Nelly
Quétier en sait quelque chose prime et
l'an dernier pour le film Annette cette
menteuse forte de 40 ans d'expérience
est venue présenter sa récompense aux
élèves de son ancien lycée de
Mantes-la-Jolie dans les Yvelines une
rencontre qui lui a permis aussi de
faire découvrir son métier écouter là au
micro de Céline Charles pour TV 78 la
chaîne des Yvelines j'ai essayé de
trouver des photos j'ai très peu de
photos de moi dans une salle de montage
c'est quelque chose qu'on confirme pas
c'est pas c'est quelque chose on
comprend pas en photo le montage c'est
un moment intime on est on est trois
dans une salle montage et un réalisateur
la matière et le monteur c'est quand
même un métier assez mystérieux
ça relève de beaucoup de choses et peu
de gens savent à quoi ça consiste
il est l'un des jeunes visages de la
boxe en France à 24 ans Naïm bellahcen
et l'un des rares boxeurs professionnels
de Haute-Savoie former chez lui dans sa
ville par ces ongles et son père il rêve
aujourd'hui de grandeur et de titres
mais avant cela il a encore tout
approuvé au plus haut niveau un
reportage signé Sébastien Germain pour
la rédaction de 8 Mont-Blanc
à 24 ans Naïm belhasen incarne peut-être
le visage de la boxe osa voyarde de
demain choyer couvé et façonné ici chez
lui au Boxing Club de Bonneville c'est
athlète complet est aujourd'hui un des
rares boxeurs professionnels du
département face à ce constat il est
toujours du conscient de faire partie
d'une certaine carte ce que ça
représente déjà c'est une fierté parce
que je me dis que c'est mon père et mon
oncle qui m'ont formé on n'a pas besoin
d'aller d'aller à Paris ou dans des
grandes villes pour pour se performer
la pleine mesure de son talent en
février dernier après 8 mois éloigné des
rings suite à une grave blessure au
métacar le Bonnevillois renouer avec le
succès en battant Kevin germoir et si
son prochain combat est prévu pour
l'instant le 20 mai celui qui a
longtemps hésité entre la boxe et le
football on voit beaucoup plus loin donc
j'aimerais bien pour commencer
être champion de France après défendre
plusieurs fois mon titre et de champion
d'Europe et monter monter le champion du
monde vraiment c'est vraiment ça mon
objectif et je vois loin parce que je
vais je sais que je vais le faire comme
très souvent dans le noble art la scène
la box est avant tout une histoire de
famille Mohamed l'oncle de Naïm a créé
le Boxing Club de Bonneville en 2002 et
il est aujourd'hui un des entraîneurs du
haut savoyard et pour la structure très
soutenue par la municipalité le passage
en professionnel de Naïm n'est pas sans
conséquence ça pue beaucoup de choses
parce que nous derrière aussi on doit
monter le niveau bon on a les boxeurs
amateurs à côté on a on a la box
éducative mais derrière bah on a le
boxeur pro avec nous on a déjà eu deux
pro avant donc pour ça c'est bien parce
que ça nous a ça nous a déjà formé donc
pour pas tomber dans les pièges puisque
aujourd'hui il est encore très difficile
de vivre de la boxe en France Naïm
Belhassen a récemment fait un appel aux
dons pour venir compléter son groupe de
sponsor c'est donc aujourd'hui tout un
club et presque même toute une ville qui
pousse fort derrière son champion et qui
sait peut-être un jour une photo à
l'effigie de Naïm Belhassen viendra
orner les murs du club Bonnevillois
entre deux légendes de la discipline
voilà et des rêves plein la tête et les
yeux les jeunes rugbymen martiniquais en
avait aussi ces derniers jours ils ont
pu approcher comme vous le voyez sur ces
images le vrai trophée de la Coupe du
monde de rugby la compétition
internationale qui se tiendra en
septembre en France fait évidemment
rêver ces jeunes sportifs propos
recueillis par Jean-Marc quarteron pour
via à TV Martinique sur place
elle est toute belle la coupe moi je
suis content de l'avoir vu ça donne
envie de jouer pour pour la gagner
la nature elle quoi la seule qu'on
présente au joueur et qui se déplace
dans les départements d'outre-mer c'est
énorme pour les enfants allez encore un
peu de rêve et de magie pour terminer ce
journal avec l'univers de la saga Harry
Potter présenté en plein cœur de Paris
Harry Potter l'exposition se tient en ce
moment même à la Porte de Versailles une
occasion unique pour les petits comme
pour les grands en savoir un peu plus
sur le monde des sorciers grâce à cette
exposition Poudlard et ses décors
n'auront plus de secrets pour vous plus
d'informations sur le site internet de
l'événement Harry
potter-exposition.fr voilà c'est la fin
de cette édition merci d'avoir suivi ce
grand JT des territoires on se retrouve
très vite pour une prochaine édition au
revoir à tous
[Musique]